[Music]
so these days I want to go back to the
to the to the better days when I want to
I want to I want America to take me back
to the days when people were like you
know what
Asians are good at math and the
stereotypes like Oh agents can't drive
but then these days you know it's like
real consequences like [ __ ] y'all broken
Rona is dangerous violence right we're
experiencing real racism no real race
you know what I wished so I wished
there's two things I wish that the kung
fu stereotype was true with the Asian
guy - you get your ass beat and like I
wish we all do comfortable oh [ __ ] this
was really know kung fu or they beat the
[ __ ] out of Asian guy and then they go
away they don't know kung fu so we can't
use a stereotype anymore hmm at least we
erase one or make it beneficial yeah I
wish we all knew math really well that
would have been great mmm I wish I think
it was scarier in the 1940s probably
probably you're right about that because
there's just a lot more [ __ ] that went
down there but the thing is now I think
like we kind of unveiled a lot of the
racism and one in Bay Area out of all
places people are being targeted with
hate mail like there's this lady that's
going around town leaving letters of get
out of my country right so in San
Leandro California I'm gonna put a
picture where's that you're from the bay
north it's south of Oakland oh isn't
that near you I'm like right below
Oakland all right we have this we have
this Karen looking character right here
with a usab because she has to represent
all right she has to represent she
doesn't [ __ ] around she's like she's in
case there was any mistake yeah this
she's American just in case you know you
don't you get make sure okay and then
she has this letter that she was just
dropping off into all these peoples she
wrote a bunch of letters she wrote a
[ __ ] like in it's written it's printed
it's the same thing over
Ronna CLE the most unamerican thingy to
do right she's like if you are a woman
or man and was born in another country
returned go back to your land
immediately fast with urgency that's
what the note said you have good English
one American white brave that serves the
nation or USA is going to live here her
name is Nancy audit chigi which doesn't
sound like a pure white America wait
white yeah Nancy our chica first
American peoples may be basically it
says no Asians allowed leave immediately
and there was just mad like straight-up
things that that kind of comes out of
like 1940 like who the [ __ ] says that
and out of all the places the Bay Area
you know it's weird it's a lot of
stories like that out of the Bay Area
why the baby out because it's a lot of
[ __ ] Asian yeah yeah this bin but I
feel like maybe now because of like it's
like Silicon Valley blowing up maybe
there's a [ __ ] ton moving yeah cuz like
when I grew up there it's all like
Filipinos and write-ins and like
everyone you could pick up a like
majority minorities maybe she maybe
there's a bunch of just closeted racist
now there's coming out never reason
because they were around all these Asian
people they've just been like all these
[ __ ] hey I've never felt that anyone
told you get a contract Apple country
nah Chinese lady tell us get out of our
country get out of her country and I
think she was crazy no no like we were
waiting in line getting fun stuff and
then she she looked at our group and
she's like go back to China out of my
country and then she walked away and
we're like I think she's crazy Chinese
lady a Chinese lady with a Chinese
accent she was walking by us we were
waiting in line
oh this was actually at Savoy and she
turned to us and she goes go back to
China
go back to China she did Sheva American
flag umbrella - was it that lady I think
I don't know cross industry finale she
and she wasn't looking where she was
walking she was just crossing the street
cars were just like needing to stop her
and she would she started yelling at
some boy yeah she was yelling at all of
us and we're like what so I I
experienced that that but I think she's
just gone maybe she's schizophrenic or
stuff I don't know if that's the right
one but you know she's just gone like
she's I don't know what she saw that's
not even good skits or friend is it like
the good kind where like you start
speaking and actually French you know
people get a Clarkson or some [ __ ] and
now that like split last person I just
oh yeah I think I mix it up with yeah
yeah split personality schizophrenia is
is just a fragmented brain because if
she thinks she's a Karen but she's still
got a Chinese accent yeah full-blown
Karen you know well maybe it's like that
should help maybe she's blind people
have been telling her whole life this is
why yeah I hate it when people will be
like where you from and like America and
they're like no but where are you from
like were you you gotta do that back to
them actually Santa Barbara I don't even
mind I don't mind that I guess I mind Oh
like like where's your family from and
what kind of Asian art they said where's
your family from that might have been
different but it's always like no where
are you from treating her like a
foreigner when she's super American like
we're all super American but then like
they see us as Outsiders I think that's
the underlining ignorance that's kind of
offensive right what did I get like why
I do let it pass those because they
don't know how to communicate yeah so
they really just want to know you better
and the intention is like oh I want to
know more about your culture yeah that's
how I always saw it too like Oh
someone's just trying to make small talk
you know whenever I get here with the
way you from I I'm like you talking
about city was set our ribs
because in Italy it could be like all
from West Hollywood you're from downtown
you know yeah but yeah it's always like
no but like where are you from like
what's your background I'm like I didn't
use that do it back to them like why are
they from like what kind of white
country they're from maybe they might
get it I've done it before once and
they're like you know if you're Irish or
Scottish or like spicy white like from
Greece or Italy or like you know I
anyway my favorite was this like
Kentucky as guy knows what living in
Hollywood I was passing the corner he
was trying to sell like tour brochures
to like take the red bus tour around LA
and he just immediately starts speaking
Spanish to me him though he's trying
doesn't seem like a racist though I am
NOT saying it's racist I'm saying it's
ignorant because I'm not Hispanic at all
and so to just assume that just right
off the bat how did it sound it was
sound of 2000 first of all the
experience something like that but for
me it's like when I travel to foreign
countries like in Europe especially I
don't know why in Europe this is so
prevalent maybe they don't have enough
Asians or whatever but like I always get
this they don't do in the mocking way I
know what their intentions are to be
polite they're like oh this has got to
be your custom you look Asian you're
Asian so then they're like I think as a
chinese-american I'm like well never
once in my life ever ever lose that like
realistically in a greeting you know I'm
like give me your [ __ ] hand and I'll
shake it that's what I wish I knew how
to touch cuz I just like this
I feel like this is what happens right
like they go to Thailand they [ __ ]
love it out there the [ __ ] right and
they're just trying to recreate that
feeling with you yeah and you're like
I'm not Thai bro with the flood cuz you
know I feel like I do the same [ __ ] but
it's not as awkward cuz I'm cuz I'm
Asian oh sure I'll be out there like and
then like we went to Malaysia and like
there's this way that they do their
[ __ ] like thank you like it was so
sick remember that yeah yeah yeah like
Saint greet you bring people closer yeah
you kind of reminded me of I think like
the Polynesians they happen where you
know they put their foreheads together
to share the same air but it's a support
it brings two people together really
close something like that anyone when I
go to Hawaii like you know man I got
family there but I really know no
[ __ ] local right but then like
because I'm Asian I feel like they treat
me easier like a local so then when I
meet a Hawaiian or like some local that
was there and I'm all brah what's up bro
bro bro what's up brah and I just feel
like I'm just trying to create that
feeling that I got in Hawaii you know
and I feel welcome this [ __ ] Hawaii okay
that's how white people do it like they
go to Japan and they may feel like that
energy so then like they'll meet a
Japanese American and don't be like oh
hello Takashi fun but then also you
don't want to be that white guy who had
like like a black friend in college so
then every black do they need but they
don't talk like this anybody else yeah
that's one around my man my man my man
that's so true oh my man right there my
man well she got caught and they took
her they bought her for citation but the
thing is her bail was set to zero
dollars for low-level crimes and
misdemeanors but people felt threatened
in the neighborhood she so far Rasmus is
Asian homes hmm specifically isn't that
hey it's a hick yeah she was charged
with the hate crime zero dollars not on
the bail yeah for a hate crime it's like
they're like like an annoying thing like
she wouldn't you know a non violent hate
crime spray with water next time yeah
right yeah right early yeah it was like
a negative YouTube comments but in
person right through your mailbox back
in a day what people used to do is like
open letters right they would talk [ __ ]
through the newspaper and all that snuff
like politicians and all that [ __ ] but
I'm like oh I don't know I feel like
that's more of a personal violation
nowadays cuz no one writes [ __ ]
letters mm-hmm so when someone leaves
some hurts more I would I gotta do the
work of opening it up and I'm just like
oh what the [ __ ] you're like taking the
time to read it you know that that
should be a different I don't know I
feel like that's more hateful than like
a comment on YouTube would you rather
get broken up with through a text or a
mail the mails like they really took the
time to break your heart but I would
appreciate the mail because especially
if it's written in cursive and then they
like drew like stuff on the paper if I
can pay for stamps and [ __ ] to pay for
stats I was like it's meaningful and
they have to write like my dear Joseph
from and then they have to have a name
like Ellen or something like that sign
with the [ __ ] feather feather pen I
think I would rather take my racism in
the letter yeah yeah open it just you
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] baby drew a Chinese guy with a
right side no no it's on a scroll Oh
[Music]
[Music]